austrian police say they've arrested 81
people as part of a global sting
operation led by the u.s
the fbi is claiming to have caught more
than 800 criminals worldwide
including arms and drug dealers by
tricking them into using an encrypted
app
aside from austria raids have taken
place in more than a dozen other
countries including australia where
federal police worked alongside u.s
intelligence
the app called anon was run by the fbi
security forces apparently got senior
figures in organized crime to use
and promote it and allowed the
intelligence agency to monitor
communications between
gangs the fbi legal attache in austria
hailed the sting
a major success this operation
demonstrates
how the fbi and our international law
enforcement partners
can come together to successfully combat
transnational organized crime
and drug trafficking activity
partnerships are the key to law
enforcement success
as no one country or agency can tackle
this problem alone
the operation almost broke down earlier
in the year one anonymous blogger posted
an article that called on people to stop
using the app because of safety concerns
then his blog was shut down meanwhile
australian officials defended the
legality of intercepting private
messages
the country's police commissioner reese
kershaw says it's the first time a law
has been used to intercept
telecommunications
but former cia analyst john kiriakou
told us the way the authorities
disguised public apps
as being encrypted and secure raises
serious issues
i think we should all just assume that
our communications
even our encrypted communications are
being monitored
pretty much all uh communications apps
can be used by law enforcement or by
intelligence services to spy on
average uh people in these organizations
like
nsa and gchq and cia
um they're they're working on things
that we
we can only imagine we can only
fantasize about we have no idea
the scope of the technology that they
have access to
and so i don't think it's ever safe for
the average person
the reason that they say they do it is
that it's to keep us safe it's to allow
law enforcement to collect information
on possible terrorist attacks or
criminal activities
but that's not the way the constitution
works all platforms
are compromised and that's why we should
always be
so careful in our private communications